[Music]
SURS next one is Tabasco so you know
what's with these are best for little
ones for home toothpicks lies I never
did that
holding the lil ones Tabasco me an
update after than you put toothpicks in
and then one toothpick comes out he's
done Wow
you'll never do that no yeah you know
they doubled their sales they made the
hole slightly larger are we all
frustrated with Tabasco you got to like
Forsett thing out okay another old train
with a small hole you double the size of
the hole whatever they did they made it
larger I don't know if there's a factor
- they made it larger now you're doing
the same thing twice the product comes
out and you're not even thinking twice
the product and now you go through it
twice as fast they get twice your money
I'm upset yeah yeah we don't spend
enough time lamenting inadequacies of
our own language we just stuck with it
and we use it and that is that's it and
often the language shapes how you think
I mean linguists have known this forever
so I'm still angry that we don't have a
good word for highly spicy flavors other
than calling it hot when the word hot I
would rather use for temperature whereas
in Spanish they distinguish Caliente for
picante one is temperature hot when is
spicy hot plus was so good at stealing
other people's words why can we do that
he should have just had that we could
have so been there and and none of these
would have the word hot on it so I'm
just angry so here's a past guest that
we've had the show and I'm the show you
and Jay Ferrel excellent excellent yeah
I just bumped into him on an airplane
and I said I got to introduce myself
because I'm a fan of comedians and there
I think they hold the soul of
civilization in the palm of their hand
we live in civilization they observe
civilization and they see the
interconnections that we are to take for
granted or never noticed and they make a
smile at others and especially ourselves
so I'm a huge fan of everything
comedians art and represent I try to tap
as much comedic flavor into my public
talks you know I'll go in they say old
you want to love a lavalier mic I know I
give me a handheld mic because then it's
a prop you can like knock on a door you
can knock on your head you can change
the volume it gives you another
dimension of communication so he knew
who I was and I was flattered by that
and we saw I just took a picture so my
my actual tweet was met NBC SNL's Jay
Pharoah and flight a reminder that
comedy can give more lift than
aerodynamics itself and that a few years
ago you credited a game-winning field
goal by the Cincinnati Bengals over the
Seattle Seahawks to being aided perhaps
by the rotation of the earth is not a
perhaps I know the rotation of the earth
shifted the path of the ball a third of
an inch to the right and that ball hit
the left upright and then careened in
through the post so there's no
supposition about being helped by
Earth's rotation the question is whether
Earth's rotation was enough of a
difference to make it go in that's all
the goalposts is round and the ball is
round you hit a round thing against a
round thing fractions of an inch make a
difference as any baseball player knows
trying to get a round ball with a wooden
bat a fraction of an inch is the
difference between a homerun and a
pop-out bangle said yeah God was on our
side or whatever and and it made a lot
of local news in each of the two towns
what it meant was if there's any kind of
science that attaches to what is already
a pop culture interest people they want
it
3:57 Mad Dog
okay can I tell you what I did yes or
should I take a bite in and tell you
maybe tell me first and just in case
just in case yeah just in case so my
sister had a dog any time I visit was
always begging at the table always you
know this is what dogs do they act like
they have never eaten in their life okay
with sad eyes so the dog was there and I
said I'm going to solve this once and
for all
and I was eating chalupas with jalapeno
peppers on them so I said let me give it
some of the ground beef gave dogs on the
ground so I got the dog accustomed to
just eating whatever I toss in her
direction and then came the jalapeno
slice so the dark and then oh my gosh
the talk that looked around like this
the tail went between the legs and
darted into the other room and the dog
never begged at my plate again one slice
of jalapeno pepper so mad dog that's how
you take care of dogs I'm just saying
[Music]